the jurgen experience dude you ever hear
about what
ben franklin was okay that's a different
story but what did he do you never heard
that like what he was found in it they
found in his house no like tons of
bodies bro
what ben franklin they found tons of
bodies in his ben franklin was a serial
killer no he was like doing some weird
[ __ ] dude bodies like experimenting yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
is this real
everything i say was ben franklin's
basement filled with skeletons
repairs on franklin's old london house
turned up 1200 pieces of bone from at
least 15 people
holy [ __ ]
for nearly two decades by the way this
is from the smithsonian
this is not some wacky conspiracy this
ain't samtripoli.com
for nearly two decades leading up to the
signing of the declaration of
independence benjamin flank franklin
lived in london in a house on 36 craven
street in 1776 franken left his english
home to come back to america more than
200 years later 15 bodies were found in
the basement buried in a secret
windowless room beneath the garden in
1998 conservationists were doing repairs
on 36 craven looking to turn franklin's
old haunt into a museum
from a one meter wide one meter deep pit
over 1200 pieces of bone were retrieved
remnants of more than a dozen bodies
said benjamin franklin's house
six were children
forensic investigation showed that the
bones dated to franklin's day holy [ __ ]
the most plausible explanation is not
mass murder but an anatomy school run by
benjamin's young friend and protege
william hewson
oh just an anatomy yeah and we're just
gonna bury them downstairs
okay anatomy was still in its infancy
but the day's social and ethical mores
frowned upon it a steady supply of human
bodies was hard to come by legally so
houston hunter and fields other pioneers
had to turn to grave robbing
either paying professional resurrection
men to procure cadavers or digging them
up themselves to get their hands on
specimens
researchers think 36 craven was an
irresistible spot for houston to
establish his own anatomy lab the tenant
was a trusted friend and the landlady
was his mother-in-law and he was flanked
by convenient sources for corpses bodies
could be smuggled from graveyards and
delivered to the wharf at one end of the
street or snatched from the gallows at
the other end
when he was done with them houston
simply buried whatever was left of the
bodies in the basement rather than sneak
them out for disposal elsewhere and risk
getting caught and prosecuted for
dissection and grave robbing
franken was probably aware of the
illegal studies going on in his building
says the benjamin franklin house but
it's doubtful that he was involved
himself still we can't imagine that
curious man that he was he didn't sneak
down and check out the proceedings at
least once or twice
of course he did
could you imagine if you're my friend
and we live together and i say sam what
are you up to you're like bro we got to
find out how people work and there's
only one way to do it we got to look at
bodies whoa how do you do that we got to
find a place where we can [ __ ]
legally or secretly look at bodies well
i'm going to basement okay so what do we
do with the bodies
but back then when they were studying
medicine
isn't that what they did
like
all those people that like studied
anatomy back then how did they if it was
illegal
to study anatomy if it was illegal to
study bodies how how else would they
find out
how anatomy worked that seems weird but
who knows they had weird laws back then
but it does seem weird but it makes
sense right because if they had never
studied anatomy before and then all of a
sudden it came along and like we gotta
[ __ ] up your grandpa you gotta carve
grandpa up like a turkey to find out
what makes people tick
you know
so weird note to add in another article
about this oh boy
franklin's history as a mason was one of
the historian's initial points of
inquiry though shrouded in secrecy
masonic rituals have dark known
undercurrents which have at times gone
horribly wrong for example in a 2004
initiation ceremony a new member was
accidentally shot by a member who meant
to fire an empty gun but instead fired a
loaded one so yeah they fake shot at
each other yeah but when historic and
historians dug deeper into what was
going on in the franklin home during the
years the bones dated back to they
discovered the real culprit behind the
bones was one of william houston
yeah they're basically saying the same
thing crazy right